he tells me everything and some things i
want to hear and some things i don't me
too man like he came home excited one
night and he was like hey i gotta ask
you a couple questions
oh that might make it a little
uncomfortable
going over ashley on friday
and we're going to be alone together
we're going to be doing some things i've
never done before
so
i just got a couple questions because
we're going to be kissing and my eyes
are going to be shut right i go yes
don't be creepy open-eyed kissy guy
that's the worst imagine opening your
eyes and seeing just somebody staring
directly at you
eyes wide open like you're a freaking
psycho i go yeah dude eyes eyes
definitely definitely closed he goes
good
question number one
answered maybe i just should have called
it after question one might have been
good for both of us and he goes you know
i know what to do here his bra move is
terrible but i didn't want to tell him
how to do a bra because i left high
school not knowing how to do a bra you
got to figure it out yourself i had
questions that you couldn't answer when
i wanted to see boobs in high school my
bra move was this
you know when you put it up
you put it on top of the titties and it
like cuts them in half and you're like
why are they so sick
and then he goes and then dad and he
starts to do this
and he's looking right at me he goes and
then dad and i'm like oh i knew i should
have gotten high for this conversation
i was probably high for that
conversation
he's walking his fingers down his
stomach
and he goes this is where i hear things
get a little tricky
i said yeah whoever told you that was
right and so for every first timer don't
be embarrassed it gets easier anyways
let me start over okay kissing eyes
closed boobies know what to do there
take a walk down to tricky town here we
are
what i need to know from you dad is when
like when you're like when you're
[Music]
dabbing you
when i have kids i'm just gonna show
them this video and it's just online
learning and i won't have to do anything
how do you touch a woman's banana dad
how do you do that
and i was like you want me to tell you
how
that's broke
i don't know dude
i can't tell you
and i said you think i'm gonna give you
my secrets i'm not giving you my secrets
i worked hard for those secrets every
man in america we also hard for those
secrets right trial and error trial and
error trial and error let's be honest
you don't have any secrets
every man in america stumbled out of the
gates you think i'm gonna kick you to
the finish line [__] you figure it out
like the rest of us did nothing better
than a [__] you from your dad you don't
call from a princess to sorcerer in one
day that's all i'm saying
pretty sure it took harry potter seven
movies i don't [__] know eight
whatever as always thank you guys for
coming by and for checking us out we
really appreciate the uh the love and
support please make sure you hit the
like button hit the notification button
and most importantly hit that subscribe
button take zero dollars to do it zero
dollar zero cents but it helps us out
immensely don't forget my dad and i do a
podcast called hey man the outpouring
amount of support for that has been also
just
amazing and we really really appreciate
you guys and wouldn't be here or doing
anything this without you guys so thank
you again make sure you guys have a
great day and we'll see you next time
[Music]
hmm
night
[Music]